Él mismo era el Einstein no solo de la Constitución de EE.UU.,
sino de un pensamiento constitucional más global,
y, hay que reconocerlo, él lo sabía.
En un período de solo tres años,
de 1785 a 1788,
concibió, teorizó, diseñó, aprobó y logró ratificar
la Constitución de EE.UU.
Y solo para darles una idea de la enormidad
de lo que representaba este logro,
ni siquiera Madison pudo saber en ese momento
que hoy la misma tecnología constitucional que él inventó sigue en uso
no solo en EE.UU., sino, 230 años después,
en lugares como Canadá,
India,
Sudáfrica,
Brasil.
En un rango extraordinario de contextos en todo el mundo,
esta tecnología sigue siendo dominante,
la más usada y la más efectiva para gestionar la gobernanza.
En ese momento,
Madison creía que, habiendo resuelto esto,
el país funcionaría sin problemas, y que había diseñado una tecnología
que minimizaría los resultados de las facciones
y que así ya no habría partidos políticos.
Sorprendentemente, pensó que había diseñado una constitución
en contra de los partidos políticos, que los haría innecesarios.
Tuvo una cantidad enorme de ayuda
en la fase final de promoción de su proyecto constitucional
de un hombre que puede que conozcan, llamado Alexander Hamilton.
Hamilton era todo lo que Madison no era.
Era apasionado, mientras que Madison era reservado.
Él era pansexual,
mientras que Madison no le habló a una mujer
hasta sus 42 años,
y luego se casó con Dolley y vivieron felices durante 40 años.
(Risas)
Para decirlo sin rodeos, Hamilton era el tipo de persona
de quien uno escribiría un musical de hip-hop,
(Risas)
y Madison el tipo de persona
de quien uno "no" escribiría un musical de hip-hop.
(Risas)
De hecho, ningún tipo de musical.
Pero juntos,
conformaban una pareja dispareja,
y produjeron los Documentos Federalistas, que ofrecieron una justificación
y, como he mencionado,
un plan de promoción para la Constitución,
que resultó ser muy eficaz y tuvo un éxito rotundo.
Con el establecimiento del gobierno, Hamilton fue Secretario del Tesoro,
y tenía una idea muy específica en mente.
Pensaba hacer con las instituciones financieras y con la infraestructura
exactamente lo mismo que Madison había hecho con las constituciones.
De nuevo, todos sus contemporáneos lo sabían.
Uno de ellos le dijo a Madison, a quien pudo no gustarle mucho,
que Hamilton era el Newton de la infraestructura.
La idea era bastante sencilla.
Hamilton le daría a EE.UU. un banco nacional,
una deuda nacional permanente,
—dijo que sería "inmortal", su frase—
y una política de fabricación que haría posible el comercio y la manufactura
en lugar de la agricultura,
que era la principal fuente de ingresos del país, y siempre lo había sido.
Madison era completamente incisivo.
Y en esta decisión crucial y crítica,
en vez de solo decirle al mundo que su viejo amigo Hamilton
estaba equivocado y adoptando las políticas equivocadas,
en realidad empezó a aducir
que las ideas de Hamilton eran inconstitucionales,
que violaban la propia naturaleza de la Constitución
que ambos habían redactado juntos.
Hamilton respondió de la forma esperada.
Declaró a Madison "enemigo político personal",
estas son sus palabras.
Así que estos dos fundadores que fueron amigos íntimos y aliados tan cercanos
y grandes socios, empezaron a enemistarse.
Y lo hicieron a la viaja usanza.
Primero, fundaron partidos políticos.
Madison creó un partido llamado Partido Republicano Democrático,
"Republicano", abreviado,
y Hamilton creó un partido llamado Partido Federalista.
Estos dos partidos adoptaron posturas en política nacional
que eran extremas y exageradas.
Para darles un claro ejemplo:
Madison quien siempre creyó que el país tendría algunas industrias,
algo de comercio, y algo de agricultura,
empezó a atacar a Hamilton
por ser herramienta de los mercados financieros
a los que Hamilton quería poner a cargo del país.
Eso fue una exageración, pero era algo que Madison llegó a creer.
También atacó la vida urbana,
y dijo que las costas eran corruptas,
y que había que mirar hacia adentro, al interior del país,
a los agricultores, que eran la esencia de la virtud republicana,
y que se debía volver a los valores que habían hecho grande a EE.UU.,
sobre todo a los valores de la Revolución,
los valores de los impuestos bajos,
de la agricultura
y de menos comercio.
Hamilton respondió diciendo que Madison era ingenuo,
que era infantil,
y que su objetivo era convertir a EE.UU. en una autarquía primitiva,
autosuficiente y completamente ineficaz a escala mundial.
(Risas)
Ambos lo sentían,
y había algo de verdad en todas sus afirmaciones,
porque cada lado estaba exagerando las opiniones del otro
para dar batalla.
Fundaron periódicos,
por primera vez en la historia de EE.UU.,
las noticias que la gente recibía pasaban totalmente por la lente
o del partido Republicano o del partido Federalista.
¿Cómo terminó esto?
Resultó que la Constitución hizo su trabajo.
Pero hizo su trabajo de maneras sorprendentes
que el propio Madison no había anticipado plenamente.
Primero, hubo una serie de elecciones.
Y las dos primeras veces,
los federalistas destruyeron a los republicanos.
Madison estaba asombrado.
Por supuesto, culpó a la prensa.
(Risas)
Y en una visión bastante innovadora,
Madison nunca dejó de innovar cuando pensaba en algo,
dijo que la prensa era tan pro-federalista porque los anunciantes eran federalistas,
porque eran comerciantes de las costas que ganaban su capital de Gran Bretaña,
con la que el federalismo tenía relaciones.
Esa fue su explicación inicial.
Pero a pesar de eso, los federalistas, una vez en el poder,
promulgaron leyes que criminalizaron la crítica al gobierno
—eso sucedió en EE.UU.
Sin embargo, los republicanos lucharon,
y Madison comenzó a enfatizar la libertad de expresión,
que había construido en la Declaración de Derechos,
y la capacidad de la sociedad civil
de organizarse.
Indudablemente, a nivel nacional,
pequeños grupos locales —se les llamó Sociedades Democrático-Republicanas—
empezaron a formarse y a protestar contra la hegemonía federalista dominante.
Al final, los republicanos lograron ganar una elección nacional,
eso fue en 1800.
Madison fue Secretario de Estado,
su amigo y mentor Jefferson fue presidente,
y en realidad, con el tiempo,
lograron sacar a los federalistas por completo del panorama.
Ese era su objetivo.
Ahora, ¿por qué sucedió eso?
Sucedió porque en la estructura de la Constitución
había varias características que manejaban a la facción
como se suponía que se debió hacer en primer lugar.
¿Cómo fue eso?
Primero, lo más importante,
la libertad de expresión.
Esta era una idea innovadora en ese entonces.
Es decir, que si estabas fuera del poder,
podías decir que el gobierno era horrible.
Segundo,
la organización de la sociedad civil.
La capacidad de reunir grupos privados, individuos,
partidos políticos y otros
que se organizan para lograr un cambio fundamental.
Quizás lo más significativo fue la separación de poderes,
un elemento extraordinario de la Constitución.
La cuestión de la separación de poderes,
lo hizo entonces y lo hace ahora,
pone el gobierno en el centro.
Se puede ser elegido presidente en EE.UU. con la ayuda de la periferia,
derecha o izquierda.
Resulta que
en realidad, no se puede gobernar a menos que estés en el centro.
Hay elecciones a mitad de mandato que vienen increíblemente rápido
tras el comienzo de una presidencia.
Eso lleva a los presidentes al centro.
Hay una estructura en la que el presidente ni regula ni gobierna,
sino que solo puede proponer leyes y ver si otras personas están de acuerdo,
otra característica que suele llevar a los presidentes
que quieren impulsar su agenda, hacia el centro.
Y una mirada a los periódicos de hoy les revelará
que estos principios siguen operando por completo.
Sin importar cómo sea elegido un presidente,
el presidente no puede hacer nada
a menos que primero siga las reglas de la Constitución,
porque de lo contrario,
se le expedirá en los tribunales, como de hecho ha ocurrido a veces,
recientemente y en el pasado, en la historia de EE.UU.
Y además, el presidente necesita gente,
funcionarios electos que sepan que necesitan ganar elecciones
de electores de centro,
también para respaldar sus políticas y aprobar leyes.
Sin eso, no pasa mucho.
Algo que pueden llevarse de esta breve digresión
sobre la historia del partidismo, es lo siguiente:
el partidismo es real;
es profundo;
es extraordinariamente poderoso,
y es terriblemente inquietante.
Pero el diseño de la Constitución es mayor que el partidismo.
Nos permite manejar el partidismo cuando es posible,
y nos permite realmente superar la división partidista
y producir compromisos, siempre que sea posible.
Esta es una tecnología que funcionó
para los fundadores,
funcionó para sus nietos,
no funcionó en la Guerra Civil, pero luego empezó a funcionar otra vez.
Y funcionó para nuestros abuelos, para nuestros padres,
y va a funcionar para nosotros.
(Aplausos)
Así que deben hacer algo muy simple.
Luchen por lo que creen,
apoyen a las organizaciones que les importan,
hablen de los temas que les importan a Uds.,
participen,
hagan cambios,
expresen su opinión,
y háganlo con respeto, con el conocimiento y la confianza
de que solo trabajando juntos
la tecnología constitucional funcionará para lo que fue pensada.
Luchen por lo que creen, pero respiren profundamente al hacerlo.
Todo va a estar bien.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)